do you have a favorite Robert De Niro
film I yeah I loved him and casino and
Goodfellas top five for me do you have a
favorite Robert De Niro film
no I I
um I it's different with me because I'm
very critical of myself so
I put a lot of uh work into Raging Bull
obviously I just did a movie actually
with Barry Levinson
um where I played two parts two
characters and we have scenes together
so that's interesting I don't say that's
my favorite but I'm very curious if what
I saw those two scenes we have are
pretty interesting and work pretty well
that's it it's not my favorite but I I
I'm proud of what I did
he's so good of an actor he's like I
want to act with myself
I know so
it just happened kind of by chance